yeah no one welcome to this video which
covers round six I think of the Tata
Steel 2017 tournament yeah let's get
going
round six not that many decisive games
today but some interesting ones and I'm
going to do that let's do this like very
quickly look at each game and yeah I
focus on a cup of it um let's do this
one by one with aronia I'm playing
Carlsen that for a long time was good
number two against road number one level
it's not that hairy high rated at the
moment compared to what he was yeah this
wasn't a super interesting game which we
saw a sloth defense which is Carlton
some choice nowadays if he wants to stay
solid against e4 and yeah it worked him
it worked they had this kind of position
and Aronian had a little something like
optically it looked like maybe as a side
initiative but Carlton defended
precisely and we don't I don't want to
go in this in any detail this looks nice
for white yeah but at the end these
these two don't do that much and black
is able to expel that Queen yeah that
looks a bit annoying but you get rid of
it and ultimately um yeah get the
position sorted there was a trade with
this little combination and we help this
dissipated into a draw quite quickly the
next game I want to check I just do it
like in the order of my know would see
which has no particular order I think is
Giri Nippon Ichi so Giri has currently
has this I think the run of 14 draws in
a row which not quite untypical anyway
we have a night walk and this time g3 is
played we've seen a couple couple of two
games with a three that's already in
this tournament and now g3 this is
actually I think a somewhat underrated
line and I think an interesting option
for wide what I'm surprised about is
that
most players top players could be five
you rarely see e6 which so should be a
very decent ravening not that if I was
bad it's just I'm a bit surprised that
it is such an overwhelming favorite of
the top players so nie de 293 is also
possible and this kind of setup I have
to say that I'm not a big expert it's
just that when I looked at this game
this kind of position we go here this
kind of position feels in my mind rather
comfortable for white he's got very
decent control over the five I mean it's
not easy to establish a piece they are
long term with the bishop being on g2
but you still have a good control black
has not gotten b5 in so there is no
direct counter play and in general black
is not they are looking very active here
so I would think that this is quite
comfortable for white however I mean a
slight slight edge however it gets
concrete very quickly rook c8 vine F um
yeah okay that's it half open file and
now rook e1 age six age six is probably
plate yeah first of all to make some
loot for the King but Knight f6 you
maybe don't want to face Bishop g5
Bishop h3 now interesting move by Gary
looking at this pin and um yeah the next
move is just a blunder it seems yeah
black now played rook to c6 and this
move just fails um he had a couple of
alternatives bishop c64 examples what
the engine wants to play it's not the
most logical I mean it's not a logical
follow up to rook c8 because in some
cases here like after a Queen move or so
in you sometimes have to play there sir
but the thing is what he did did no work
he played this and if you like you can
treat
this is a little tactical exercise right
to play and win us a bit much but to be
much better and the move is Bishop h6
know it takes a check and that's it for
the night and this is just a pawn just a
pawn
yeah basically black blundered this h6
born Wow well with the capture the g7 if
you want and wide now has of course much
better it is not a totally simple win
because black has Bishop d2 this double
attack him so he gets to take on c3 and
White has this double pawn now this
isn't itself not such a big issue those
pawns are weakest but those are as well
and um Geary is a very good technical
player he sometimes misses the
conversion of good positions in a
technically very messy position but he
is excellent in 10 in technical play and
he does not really allow how much you
know f4 is good you know threatening
this and just yeah dynamically playing
dynamically like took it Andy five
that's very nicely played if I've just
look to take this I mean in a situation
where you keep the pawn and first and
foremost we should be fourths idea it's
a nice move black Bishop c8 you go back
and now the d6 pawn gets taken and the D
pawn is quite obviously extremely strong
and yeah it was very nicely played now
rook c6 is not the most precise move and
there was some improvement over that oh
no I'm sorry
yeah root do you want rook t1 is skewed
bishop 87 is the idea in case of root d6
and he a could have defended a little
bit tougher here with Bishop d7 the
position is very bad for black
though King f8 however what was played
in the game is losing immediately due to
Bishop a6 nice tactic takes d7 and
promotes and yeah after after this
capture on g3 they for me actually
resigned he cannot stop the D pawn
simply here Bishop b5 and t7 is
impossible to prevent all the
immediately 7 depending on what black
does so a fairly easy when actually for
Geary
they probably actually really blundering
with Roxy six so this is the end of
Geary's drawing streak he ended it with
the win and yeah this is the thing with
his drawing streaks and he draws lots of
games but he's very rarely worse in
those games so it's mostly being
comfortable in with his drawers and this
is some not such a terrible style to
have it's just that if he would convert
more he would be an absolute monster for
us to be reckoned with
okay he went he won this game and it's
now one plus one in this tournament it's
easy to calculate here was someone who
would never lose this and he wins the
game is on plus one he wins another one
is a plus two okay so that was give
again can sniff a Yahtzee and the next
in my list here in no particular order
is van really with one against
Dmitri and raking yeah that was a really
long game and a super complicated game
where I feel I can probably not give you
totally yeah - totally complete correct
with everything coverage because it's
just such a monster of the game and
interesting opening year a 6-pound
raking what is the point of this move it
looks a bit strange right what is a6
doing and it has an idea and then really
plays Knight c3 we will see what happens
after that move I think one idea of a
six in this particular position is that
after g3 you might just go b5 I know it
looks weird but this is not so bad it
seems no you get to feel hello and
if you can trade be against see porn or
get this pay attention going this is not
so bad now it would increase your
control on the light squares quite a lot
it doesn't feel all that bad there are
ideas like that against the English
opening where the pawn is still on d2
and why shouldn't it be possible with
the pawn on d4 so interesting
however Knight c3 was played and now and
rake in just 25 so we transpose into a
Queens gambit declined where black
essentially has played somewhat exotic
looking for a 6 but that does actually
have some points the most or the the
crucial choice if a white is do you take
on d5 or not if you don't take on d5 and
play like let's say Bishop f4 a very
normal move in the Queens gambit you
have to reckon with black taking and
here b5 is just now a possibility as a6
is useful for that so something like
this is definitely a playable line for
black warm you can do the same thing
after Bishop g5 and black takes yeah
compare this to the board Winnick
variation where c6 would be plane
instead of a 6
I mean c6 has one purpose to play b5 and
why shouldn't a six serve the same
purpose or comparable purpose this is a
playable position so quite interesting
right now it took and now you get the
Queens gambit declined exchange where
again a 6s plate this however is not
that bad move I mean it does have some
points we see how it goes
Bishop e5 Bishop e6 this is interesting
this is now a possibility as screen to
b3 black has a couple of options he can
even play Knight be d7 and just ignore
b7 being attacked I have seen b5 being
played even which is yeah
a bit under on the loose side maybe but
it's very interesting even that again as
possible if Y takes who create and Luke
takes me to it's a this is interesting
it's absolutely unclear so III and
normal development let's say age six
bishop age form yeah and of course black
now can play with with other setups for
example Bishop d6 this has been played
by Magnus Carlsen for example you know
yeah it doesn't it only says Doha 2016
that that must have been a rapid or
blitz game against us unsafe but should
be sixes setup it's interesting it's a
queen's gambit declined setup where
black has relatively active pieces and
this somewhat unusual configuration or
let's say interesting things to explore
really and drink and play g5 totally
different approach and now night h5
getting the the bishop while trying to
get the bishop it can run away but
should be 597 and aged three cakes
before bishop h2 comes knight takes and
i want i will to take stock a little bit
later like here yeah i think this is a
very unconventional position black has
played this aged 65 weakening himself in
the process quite a bit but he's gotten
the pair of bishops as a long-term asset
and he certainly succeeded in getting a
yeah something that you can fight with
it's not just a boring position or
something and it sometimes happens in
the Queens gambit declined exchange it
can be quite a dull experience for black
here I think however here over does it a
bit he plays aged five now and move like
c6 probably was better one point is that
white has the idea to play FY 5 and if F
for now I think it's not as good as in
the
by far as in a situation like that Queen
b6 followed by long castles is quite
decent looking at this with a check it's
a fairly I mean it's fairly is wrong
it's a really unclear position it's
really tough to assess this however and
then f4 gets to be a problem as the
immediate f-pawn push if threatened and
yeah and rake in now when g4 but after
f5 is in quite some trouble he had to go
back and here crenate forth would have
been a good move that when when he could
have could have been played
it's a the thing is after this it's easy
to see that Bishop d7 is good for white
as you just take on d5 at the end so
this this this this and takes this is
easy and certainly was calculated by
when really everybody checks Queen a4
yeah but oops I'm sorry that's what you
played but King to f8 is a different
matter here maybe he didn't see the the
right continuation I don't know I can
only speculate it's Queen 85 this is not
a very natural move once you spot it as
a candidate it said it's kind of it once
you spotted you see that it is very
interesting that same as c6 it's not
possible it's a pin down and you're just
threatened to take this with the Queen
here black is an extreme trouble it's
probably probably and when the computer
says white wins basically Queen a 4
would have been very strong I'm not
quite sure what them miss was there f6
was plate Knight to g6 and now black is
is okay however it's a it's a super
complicated position I mean takes him
and when really even grabbed on a and h5
reaching this position and it seems that
from here he didn't play it
play it well even though yeah we are
basically dealing with a rapid game now
and in a very murky position probably
for here was to be preferred with the
better game for Whitewood
this is some or computer issue I mean oh
it's all computer supported it's a
totally different animal to play it over
the board
he played Queen to you too and now
ninety five and this is helpful for
black quite clearly yeah we got the
trade now and if we take stock it's five
pounds again six but the white pawns are
all completely not all but those they
don't coordinate at all and a mostly
weak then really tried to keep the h5
pawn with this g4 push but black now is
better yeah he's got the pressure here
and we win the pawn this ending now is
budget for black yeah it's just better
for black and we can fast forward a
little bit better for black does not
mean winning by the way yeah but we can
fast forward a little bit to the rook
and then you can look at this I
understand that I want to focus on some
moments in the rook ending so here we
have two two points against one and
those endings in comparison to rook and
pawn against rook are not really once
that you can learn by heart there are
some motifs that you can can know and
recognize but this is mostly a job of
precise calculation and playing those
correctly can be extremely extremely
difficult and they actually made a
couple of mistake and that the computer
finds quickly but for a human player
under time pressure it's extremely
tricky to do we can start here on move
46 year after f5 after f5 rook b8 was
played by when really
this is a mistake however you see
relatively quickly in the game the most
straightforward mafia would have been b5
and I think also the move that I would
always recommend to play in a practical
game because this is the clearest try to
trade off one pawn we have to be clear
on that
being a draw yeah it's a it's an easy
draw so black will play c5 this is the
only try yes to keep this farm pond on
the board
and now after who b8c for b6 not only
moves but the most logical once you get
to this position which is a draw the
right king can can come over so this was
a way to a way to do it kind of
skeptical is that really a draw it
should be a draw right this is what by
not same
yeah why does white is coming over here
right cooking c6 king of 2t3
kingi - oh I said to draw doesn't look
like a draw that's lost right that's a
lot sauce tending huh what is that did I
just miss label on my notes him I labor
route by five with equal okay
now that's not equal and that kind of
puts b5 into question I'm sorry about
that
I mean I the thing I know is that this
is a draw this is what what the engine
calculated to a total draw I looked at
this with those some of those cloud
engines that is a that is a complete an
engine draw on that same yeah okay rook
b8 was when I'm sorry about the
confusion about b5 i just mislaid with
my notes but where the end the end of
this line really was lost forward okay
what p8 it was played in the game and
now after king f4 it seems that black is
yeah indeed yeah winning b5 now i was
tried jack oopsie - king back to g1 rook
b2 b6 and now king f3 was doing doing
the trick king f3 the line that is b7 j
check king edge - King f2
yeah we have to see that if white is
trying to tray it here yeah that the
white king is ages I mean a long way far
away from the see porn
so that will win quite easily so again
king of three is the line b7 checking
edge - King F - yeah and you really like
move sir King age three is made so you
have to move the rook I just wanted to
show that
and then you get to this ending King g3
I ever was played here by black and
after King f1 everything seems to be in
order however it is still quite tricky
and there is a moment a little bit later
b7 f4 and now Luke b8 played by van Veen
it seems to lose but you know this is
basically a blitz game now and then we
have to always take this into account
seems to lose kingly one seems to be a
draw and we have to check how it was a
win he have to be eight King f2 and it's
quite nice King F to be seven f3 and
this is nice now and if you look at this
it's basically at suits on if the rook
moves then the pawn is falling so it's a
king move and he only can go here after
which weakly - Andrew t7 is extremely
strong because now again rook move costs
upon and if white plays King to see to
black plays rook d7 King takes King e2
and will promote he's really nice young
black is looking at this is shielding on
the e-file and promotes very nice in the
game King g3 was played a check
Ruby 8 and now it's funny if black plays
f3
b7 we have the same position but with
them now with black to move with white
to move he loses do two suits one but
with black to move it's a draw yeah rooo
king of one of many King mu fear would
allow the check if he go King f1 yeah
you lose this for a draw and what else
is there
if black moves the rook for example here
he's going up and again it's a draw it's
really funny it's a same position but
it's a big difference whose move this
yeah in the game oh sorry that was
button in the game King f2 was played
look f8 yeah and enter Troy yeah so
there were chances for the black to win
this game at the end but yeah it is
always extremely difficult from the
practical point of view if you are very
short of time it's a pure calculation
job it's not like oh my god this this
and this guy doesn't know his roof
endings or so it's just extremely
difficult in that in that limited time
re-bond versus Vesely so so the Indian
fighting against the tournament leader
and we got a Kings gambit that's cool
right don't see that too often in
top-level chess yeah interesting and in
fact the Kings bishops the King bishops
gambit I think it's the name which is
even rarer than Knight f3 but this is
maybe the more interesting I'm a little
bit unsure there how to how to evaluate
that well so certainly did not expect
that
and he played d5 and he called a decent
position d5 and now Knight of 6 that's
the idea with the bishop taking black
now is getting the bishop pair and yeah
develops easily and move like g5 is also
possible instead of Bishop d6
in the game we see that white got to
occupy the center really quickly and he
got this so white is a pawn up however
we have to see that there's lots going
on in the e-file and with f6 and Queen
b6 black gets active plain white has not
Castle that has to ya untangle himself a
little bit in the game black court and
not enough activity to make it make it
okay for him and I know I don't want to
analyze this in detail but you see that
black has pressure against this against
this pawn and the way it turned out
everything got got traded to
to equality and they continue it a
little bit but it ended in a draw so an
exciting start with the Kings gambit but
sometimes you can play unconventional
stuff and and then do try to do things
but it's um sometimes just in vain if
correct players it's happening it often
will end in the draw but interesting and
seeing the Kings gambit on that level
the next game on the list would be a
yarn of kayaking I don't want to shake
this too much say surprisingly onion off
24 which she doesn't do a whole that
often we had a d3 Berlin it wasn't all
that exciting maybe kayaking was a
little bit better at some point but
probably not something that did amount
to much we have the game her accretion
of water Shack which also I don't want
to check all that deeply it was quite
interesting but we have to make some
yeah some compromise David should not be
a super long video I want to get to them
by the way the creation of Watership
game was a window passed slowly through
Lopez I want to get to the report why he
came because that was the yeah I mean
this is already sounds like a wacky game
you know reporters earth the most
creative and one of the most aggressive
players around and Vallieres an
extremely gifted tactician so he's not
the kind of person who yea wants to
extinguish every fire that reporters
setting him so let's see what we got mmm
Petrov it doesn't really sound like
something interesting but just wait here
we go Knight c4 that's not a very usual
move against the petrov and objectively
speaking out so don't think it is
particularly great but it gives the game
a fresh character Knight takes Queen e2
Queen e7 is forced and now Knight to e3
and here the concrete play begins 95 is
a threat
which black is covering renewing the
threat and now yeah of course ye could
have just taken on c3 but he just went
back this is a bit more interesting this
move as 90x III is yeah accelerating
White's development a little bit Knight
f6 is not helping with that now
interestingly enough report when g3 I
say interestingly enough because chief
was actually a playable move and
whenever he has the opportunity to play
stuff like g4 I usually does so I was a
bit surprised to only only see g3 but of
course it's objectively a good move this
this black tries to sort his position a
little bit there the Queen wasn't great
on his seven maybe Bishop h3 comes into
consideration so report did disappoint a
little bit of her not playing g4 but he
can play before instead this is actually
a good move I mean it looks it looks
backe as usual but it is a good move it
just tries to go b5 and make something
out of the long diagonal okay
d5 if you are faced with playing on the
flank you should respond in the center
this is this old saying and it is
usually quite right you know there are
some of those who would say don't really
apply that much in modern chess but if
you can play in the center it's usually
a good idea no matter if the Chi place
some men on the flank or whatever a
central play is usual usually good yeah
so be 594 Queen d3 that's not the most
natural set up you know c2 d2 and the
Queen err in front of it and the Knights
in front of the pawns it's it's a bit
weird but it is some quite interesting
for concrete reasons c5 yeah covering
the knight castles and castles long so
okay why does not have his pawns in the
center but his pieces are active here
those Knights and the bishop they are
focused on the d5 square
the rupiah has something to do
potentially on the B file and the bishop
on c1 which really is kind of hurting at
the side of this pawn sometimes has a
job on b2 a3 so it's unconventional but
not bad Ruki one using the e-file
potentially and vehement h5 yeah I mean
this is not the kind of position where
you should shuffle around yeah wide will
do stuff on the queenside he's already
on b5 so black should get counter play
h4 to stop that and in this position I'm
right you also could have played more
conventional moves like him yeah Knight
f5 for example is what the engine I
think suggests but there are a couple of
ideas but he plays the most aggressive
move g5 as I said he's the kind of guy
who wants to fight fire with fire not
sitting around so g5 yeah so b6 was
played by report he also could have
taken on g5 immediately but I think
inserting b6 a 6 here this certainly
makes some sense before taking so you
could analyze this without b6 but B 6 is
a very natural human move and
objectively odds okay Knight you form
and that is Nancy text e5 so what did
black get for orders yeah he gets this
aggressive play with h4 going but it
objectively seems to be not correct the
move g5 probably was a bit too risky
verb like we will see H for now was
played and now white could have gotten a
good position and I did not see the
press conference if there was one but I
would be interested to know what exactly
it was that report did not evaluate
correctly it is of course an extremely
sharp position and
yeah if I would play that myself or
probably lose with Bose Bose colors
quickly but I would just totally mess up
the complications but I still would be
very interested to learn what his
calculation problem was because 90 XG
for now seems to be excellent for for
white first of all taking on reform does
not work YouTube you should be too
maybe this was an issue but should be -
is very strong that ideas to take on
deform for example if black takes you
take him and then you check and the
point is that this kind of situation
oops
looking aid and here is fantastic for
white he threatening Bishop e7 checkmate
so yeah black has to take and here we
see that it's simply too much white wins
the full piece in this position that
doesn't work so the only move would be
Bishop d5 but then Knight f6 and again
we want to take on d5 the only move that
continues the game would be Bishop g2
second of the Queen Knight takes a check
now White has to sacrifice it back as
this is a disaster
so takes takes and we should be - and
here why this better you know it's not a
win or anything but white is definitely
better he's up material instead sake
group here takes takes takes takes is a
better position for white we can just
count yeah it's six against for its
opposite colored bishops makes it tricky
but I mean right is better two pawns are
two pawns yeah this was played it's
extremely tempting yeah it's extremely
tempting but it does not seem to be
enough to an advantage h3 is correct and
now he had to take on g4 it seems it is
a crazy line but
it seems to be still okay for white
takes takes check and takes well it
looks crazy but at the end if you do
account you see that this is material
wise okay
yeah it's funny this this this this this
this and this is singing and this is
hanging the computer is just saying
equal yeah it's typical computer stuff
but who is going to find that in a game
yeah that's the thing yeah what report
it does not work I mean it does not work
but it looks extremely dangerous and he
he sacrificed on b7 here and the black
King has to run to c6 at first sight
you're absolutely absolutely
trembling probably with black hair your
King is running around but at the end it
does not seem to work yeah the problem
is that while blacks King looks exposed
there are not that many attacking pieces
from the white side and black has a very
quick counter player based on the age
for cornea and the the ideas here on the
light squares yeah looking at this with
deeper there's not really a big attack
it looks terrible at first for black but
there's nothing much look f1 is not what
the computers claim but this is the kind
of thing that no human would play a
black goes here and is fine Bishop g7
King can go to e7 most of the time he's
a priest piece of that was tried and
black just recaptured yeah yeah White
was throwing a little bit more wood to
the fire and there was a repetition and
now King to the six by bayi he repeated
once and then after having checked out
that nothing threatens even with the
King on d5 he went there yeah this is of
course funny and the King on d5 with the
Queen's on the board but
more close name there is not that much
going on in fact white has to work with
checks exclusively if he does not age
three check and the LightSquared pieces
the pizza is is finishing it off black
is threatening made himself so you can
for example give the check and black
just takes yeah I mean if white would
not be checkmated himself yeah you could
think of maybe a preparation move where
to set up a check for the Kingman and
you simply have no slow move I mean if
you play any I just playing some move to
show his age to age recheck and
something like that is made that's the
thing yeah report tried rookie three
yeah age two and here Quincy six was a
safe move and there were alternatives
and also one but Quincy six is good he
had to basically allow the Queen trade
now I know Black has two pieces up so
after after this we should be too he ate
but he won the game as report resigned
yeah extremely unconventional game again
by the Hungarian player and it seems he
was okay in the complications but it's
one of those cases where you are there's
lacking an expression there you get
burned by the fire that you set up
yourself basically very interesting game
though so we win here for ye in this uh
yeah this tactical technical battle so
um after round six we have still I think
Wesley is so leading with the plus three
score followed by Carl's lose on plus
two and alien off was still on plus two
the accountant has had four draws with
black which were somewhat uneventful but
it's also we have to see that the his
opponents played it very close to the
rest not risking anything and then he's
not the kind of guy who plays something
totally wacky yeah so draws in those
games that he wandered to white games
around seven
which is played on Saturday 21st sees
cards are playing white against Giri
which is interesting Giri hard to beat
but cards and definitely would want we
want to try with YTM ok I hope you
enjoyed the coverage for around 6 thanks
for watching